ciao ragazzi benvenuti nella puntata di
cucina buttata vi do una ricetta che se
volete scopata così proprio il vostro
partner avrà un esplosione orgasmica
me la fai ciao ragazzi oggi faremo una
ricetta deliziosa luogo alla cracco sul
letto alla carbonara a
parlare
[Musica]
oggi faremo un nuovo stronzone del fanta
l'andria per parigi prende tutto quanto
ispirazione in realtà dall'uomo di
creatore di ispirazione è
il tuorlo di fatah mag ho imparato
pangrattato visto che fare un nuovo di
fatah magò da solo sarebbe stato
mortificante per faremo altre cose per
rendere un pochino più belle poter
fantab olari infanta maglia
[Musica]
un ufo del pangrattato che questa
piccola stella michel
grattato comunque è veramente violante
grazie sgradevole che diverso c'è
un'altra sottolinea di questa tra
lamento anno aspetta riguarda un altro
uovo e sgradevole veramente partiamo con
il preparare il tuorlo si fa in questo
modo a versiamo pangrattato dentro una
piccola bull se volete farli per più
persone anche se un piatto va benissimo
prendete il dito e fate questa cosa qui
create un piccolo letto per il tuorlo
apriamo il tuorlo togliamo tra il guscio
il tuorlo ce lo mettiamo sulla mano che
schifo attente se non è piacevole cielo
passiamo da una mano all'altra o non
dedica da mangiare
ma
carino altra spolverata di pangrattato
a coprirlo e lo buttiamo in freezer per
23 ore 21 mai a brescia nella fiducia ma
se anche fosse seconda classe di quel
titani prima classe insieme a rosa oltre
che diffonda diciamo anche besciamella 6
la signora è arricchita
non lo sappiamo graziano è lì dietro
agata grande prepariamo una crema al
pecorino superveloce la base è una
besciamella
come sapete voi dite lo showman
besciamella ton orfano parure o paure è
proprio facilissimo fai la besciamella
un tempo facevo una tecnica che ci
metteva i secoli di mia madre mezzo
litro di latte semplice semplice 50 g di
burro e 50 grammi di farina ma non c'è
una frusta piace il calcio è questo
veloce per una putt non si dica se non
sarà così grazie questo per farvi capire
cosa che gli suggeriscono e 50 grammi di
farina al volo e
aggiungiamo latte caldo
massimo siamo quelle per montare cazzo
ci fregano alessandro non ve ne andate
le fruste
bene
pepe
occhio alla quantità di pepe che mettete
non esagerare troppo perché dal momento
che una ricetta che fanno a scopare
definiti finite che poi avete il culo in
fiamme folk energico bulgaria sta
parlando ad enego ethan e graziana e
noce moscata bellavista leggermente
pazzo che la noce moscata e a questo
punto arriva al terrore prendiamo il
pecorino di rete e quanto ce ne dobbiamo
mette ragazzi divenne a.de scovare
parlare esatto come esse abbonderà iper
contro l'odio in questa forma quando poi
che tutto quanto sciolto lavoro o
andiamo ad aggiungere proprio felici che
ha una grappa genera altro questo ios
cobham botto è viene una bella crema per
pecorino zza guarda quanto cazzo cene ai
granchi gianola de rigo se tu provi a
mangiarlo e anche solo avere mezza
elezione io ti do un pugno ma mi piace
certo così solamente non perico io conto
tempo sta passando insieme a graziana la
nostra crema al formaggio è pronta
e appena sono arrivati la linea restano
trovare che è arrivato il medico la
peste che cercano una tristezza ancora
no scusate regalo è stata diventi così a
tre domani le moretti ma nemmeno
setacciare infatti come sono ben e
pecorino a grandi grossi hanno bene sul
player nullo sticazzi per tempo o
quantomeno se facciamo bene tagliamo la
picchi poi dobbiamo stare zitti mentre
taglia perché guarda che guarda guarda
che ti fai questo lavoro 20 minuti ieri
non sento il coltello che taglia pa
non posso fa tutto di polso non siamo su
youporn siamo su youtube quindi posso
avere un mestolo
si parlava non era possibile
o dio ti ha parlato non saltano in
realtà sembra delle palline vax ancora
una volta il migliore amico termometro
da cucina porto a 180 gradi la
temperatura vi lascio il link affiliato
nell'info box i miei tuorli e poi cosa è
successo
bellissimo milano se funziona però e
alla fine abbiamo fatto di più per
essere sicuri perché ho paura che non
possa succedere
io sono quel tipo di gesù che moltiplica
i tuorli 180 gradi per 90 secondi ecco
perché è fondamentale il termometro crea
ho subito il letto di crema di pecorino
trani colpi che vuoi dare contro il
matera che sappiano al loro partiamo
prendiamo il tuorlo e in maniera super
di licata
questo è l'unico pezzo che non so
non perdere illustro sia non mi sembra
pronto ci siamo ci siamo
chi in piatta suona il campanello
[Musica]
ragazzi a questo punto passiamo
all'assaggio un business plan
[Applauso]
[Musica]
bellissimo 6 su browser
siamo ecco come delle buste
scusate silenzio
un attimo fugace arriva un insieme di
sapori rilascio di un orgasmo e ne
vorrei un altro super o da un altro per
uno tra poi ho deciso e quella persona
che assaggerà luogo a dritto su un
fondente di pecorino commenta guanciale
per poter intreccio assoluta io enrico
[Applauso]
è molto bello io sono contentissimo che
vole di aver scelto modello mangiarotti
cambio
il comitato invidiando no io io ti odio
non sei qua io e l'ho chiamato solo per
le porcate se dicessi con cui mi ha un
altro
aereo
[Musica]
è la ricetta più buona riuscita puntata
appena caterina da fare ho pregato
è pazzesco il pentito ventina cracco
certo se ci abbiamo aggiunto un pochino
di romanità se lo farete vi prego
milioni proprio salute hamas ha ieri un
secondo portati anche questo c'è questa
ricetta vi porterà a ottenere un
qualcosa di positivo nel fanta nulla pò
mettete un la chi scrive a questo canale
tra tutte noi abbiamo fatto forse la più
buona in assoluto queen ce la farete una
sola cosa è sicura dovete assolutamente
taggarmi su instagram è farmi sapere che
cosa ne pensate di questo uomo alla
cracco in versione un pochino più romana
ha detto ciò mi mando un bacio ci
vediamo domenica prossima alle 12 con
un'altra vivere così l'ha buttata
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]